please please quick now the man is
wielding a knife and he's telling me
he's clearly killed he killed david at
belfast methodist church
the call to the emergency services broke
up the calm of what had been a
relatively quiet day for essex police
you see he's always still in real time
see how can you see how big the knife is
yes it's
a it's a carbon knife a big kitchen
carving knife
you can hear the terror and the
desperation
he wants to get shot apparently he wants
to be hero we want the police to come
and shoot him
it was made moments after the mp for
south end west sir david amos had been
stabbed multiple times
the attacker 26 year old ali harby alley
was caught at the scene with knife in
hand
and the trial in which remarkably he'd
pleaded not guilty has been a harrowing
time for friends and family of the
murdered mp
has been awful and and and
really brought home how awful it was and
how distressing
it was
whilst it is irreconcilable what has
happened
and
makes me angry that we are in the
position where we are now
i think actually that he's able to he
was able to plead not guilty yes i think
actually
um as as wrong as that might appear
it is the country and the rules that we
live in and the values that we have
ali habi ali's movements on the day were
picked up on cctv as he traveled from
london to lyon c
he's seen carrying a backpack which
contained the murder weapon a large
knife he'd bought five years earlier
described as a fanatical terrorist the
attack had been years in the planning he
decided to kill the mp because of his
voting record which included air strikes
on syria
david amos was holding a surgery here
now ali habi ali had managed to get an
appointment by posing as a constituent
it took place at midday
there wasn't any security and it's
unlikely the mp would have thought that
much was wrong until moments before the
attack
he was stabbed 21 times he also had
injuries to his hands
where he tried to defend himself
and this was the moment the police
arrived on the scene
we need the taser unit here we're ta
let's say he's got a knife and he's just
stabbed
in the body cam footage the two officers
unarmed except for batons and spray are
told the mp had been attacked many times
they then move in and take him down
get it down
what's going through their mind is just
racing
and to take that step then to open that
door and commit inside that premises i
think it's an astounding act of bravery
witnesses described ali as having a look
of smugness and self-satisfaction after
the attack as though he'd achieved
something
police officers spent the following days
searching and gathering evidence from
three properties in london
it's known ali had been referred to the
counter-terrorist scheme prevent in the
past but he was not being monitored by
mi5
he didn't have a gun he didn't make a
bomb he didn't do any of the things that
might trigger a sort of law enforcement
response or or raise a red flag so in
that sense this kind of low-tech attack
is very hard for the authorities to
monitor
in a series of police interviews he
admits murder and preparing acts of
terror
mr annie is this a terrorist attack
i mean i guess yeah i killed an mp
okay
he'd researched several political
targets including the ministers michael
gove and dominic raab and the labour
leader sakia starma
he'd also tried to travel to syria to
join the islamic state but had given up
because it was too difficult to get
there
i'll be honest with you there's been a
lot of times where i've gone out
in my head with a plan to do something
and then i would come back on
so
you know because
you know what's the word i'm looking
above it
during a rapid investigation and
charging process it became clear to us
that in order to give the full picture
to the jury and indeed to the public it
was necessary to go back a couple of
years
to show this individual's thought
process
and the planning that he went through so
that now he will be sentenced for the
true extent of his crimes
at the center of all this was of course
sir david amos a hugely popular mp he
was known as mr south end
so david's legacy is compassion and it
is kindness and it is an example
for all mps about what a good
constituency mp should be somebody who
cares for every constituent every single
person in his community
the murder of david amos has once again
raised important and searching questions
about how best to protect politicians
and public officials in an open
democracy
many of them still remain unanswered
alex rossi sky news leon c